bien disposés à écouter vous êtes sûr
voulu être matt pokora dans la comédie
romain des bois non nous étions bluette
robin des bois tout court vous avez
toujours voulu être legolas vous avez
toujours voulu avoir des belles godasses
et peu mais l'idée vous avez toujours
voulu être en zoo donc ok super chez on
arrête
allez on va jouer aujourd'hui on a un
arc et une flèche donc là je crois que
en fait d'accord sa part carrément sur
du [ __ ] violon mouiller hockey en mai
outre at il il faut que je tire sur le
cube pour commencer - ivone cdma gamme
et lycées des cubes
effectivement la rue ridgewood sommes
déjà pour commencer
effectivement dans la rue souvent croisé
clique sont hyper chiant à je suis hyper
fort mais déjà arrête
j'ai bien d'eux attend un mec m'a vite à
rejoindre ce groupe d'accord je quittais
le hockey c'est reparti à temps c'est
plus une flèche de ma vraie manette
je me moque totalement les quoi on va
tâcher la valette à la corde on va
l'envoyer maison de beit et ça c'est
quoi ce brave gens voient la manette
écoulé avant que jean championne ok ok
ok les mecs qui blague pas quoique les
shops dans mon dos mais qu on good ou
pas alors je m'en bats les couilles ou
externes et demi je m'en bats les
couilles les options je avoir olalalala
mais ce ce qu'il dit mais pourquoi je
meurs je comprends pas au d'accord faut
que j'en vois deux flèches et la suite
c'est super show bike lg souhaite un
ninja mieux abuser il faut envoyer deux
flèches à chaque fois horaire des
rennais il faut que j'y tiens dessus et
tu as numérique à tort des mecs compris
mais je t'ai je vais tous vous tuer bon
bah les couillons parents bataille de de
savoir c'est une flèche
joseph mois l'oréal et hausse constante
on va passer ces [ __ ] cube c'est
parti ça change rien fait comme un
endroit où on s'en fout allez go tir
claque au est dehors et de à question à
faire qu'il soit cette flèche
c'est babu tu attends mais si je recule
en fait pour mais c'est à à à sa vanille
est allé une côte cassée c'est gratuit
c'est la sté schéma à l monsieur baiser
mais quelle corde faible y'a que moi
quel droit de le dire parce que j'aime
et qui après vous approprier le truc un
peu mais n'aura offert il ya juste qu'il
dise où je vais arriver mais que ça
vient ça vient mon grand père c'était
voldemort du coup il n'avait pas d'armé
et moi du coup je suis fort à l'art ça
n'a aucun rapport sais pas quoi ohlala
c'est passé wild 2 allez vas-y fais
péter tawake deux briquets on est prêtes
et 6 passes d'accord si je comprends
bien
si le cube je les attends il m'envoie
une double qui me fait mal si je devais
pas toi-même envoie une boule rouge qui
me fait mal ce mouvement voit on va
demander l'avis de la table tout moment
quelque chose table s'en bat les
couilles
elle s'en bat les couilles avec juste me
casser les côtes à temps mais pas je
commence début mais non mais
ok et de la haie de deux halls à la
mecque mon gars j'avoue que je fais des
petites soirées jennifer lawrence elle
m'a tout appris mon pote tu peux pas
tester le skill de lutte à oshawa assez
jouissif mon gars qu'est ce tu vas faire
chaque boum c'est bon maintenant que
j'ai trop vite en fait avant qu'il
devienne rouge c'est sa difficulté ok 2
1 le deuxième est où là haut up et mère
je me suis dit qu'est merdes le seul hic
est à ok ok mais ça m'a accroché mais
non j'ai perdu mes mecs mec mais qu'il
ya et pétition pétition
ce jeu est trop dur au revoir c'est mal
parti sous les choix président en 2017
n'hésitez pas ok on n'y va pas la boule
bas bolkiah d'accord donc la justicia y
est bannie tu peu chier qui passaient
journal alors si c'est bien une flèche
comme ça je suis robin des bois mais moi
laïque et ma page facebook
voilà robin des bois en 2016 comme ça
que le bois on va même faire des frites
shot on va ou pas c'est quoi la
technique c'est notre marque à
l'horizontale ne fait pas confiance je
dédie mon grand père il faisait chez
plus quoi mais ça avait un rapport non
mais m
c'est pour ça que j'aime prendre mon âme
dans la gueule en dessous donne moi ta
puissance
robin des bois de motel 6 ans hugo la
puissance c'est pas vieille
en fait je ne comprends il faut attendre
que le cube se tirent dessus en fait si
moi je lui tire dessus
je dois enchaîner deux flèches si
j'attends c'est moi je me comprends mais
je suis à fulham c'est un tout doux au
web chaque fois mais qu il ya un check
point thermomètre canada world sa alors
à watts après cette blague keaton
squeeze mis la clé sous la porte et
ferme à sa chaîne youtube il essayait
alors de conquérir le public anglophone
a qui n'en n'avait absolument rien à
[ __ ] de lui
vu qu'il plagie publie paille bon je
tiens c'est un peu d'humour en ces temps
durs ça fait pas de mal
ok vidéo sur un jeu d'arc dont le
trailer est beaucoup mieux que le
gameplay
voilà le trailer où sont les samouraïs
mais c'est mal et ça vous a plu et
surtout très vite dans de prochaines
voilà je dis à chaque fois je vous
apprends rien encore désolé pour ceux
cette corde sensible que j'ai touché à
la fin est temps qu'on prive à l'arc et
la blague
bon tu as changé mais qu à la saison
prochaine vidéo par thèmes ou bien tu as
tout le monde